East 2 024
reflect well and choose your rulers.
And for this
here are some phrases about politics that will help you.
The first is by Carlos Gaviria Díaz,
who says,
the one who pays to arrive
arrives to steal.
José Mujica.
Good governments
are not those who use workers' taxes.
to give them to the lazy,
but those who create conditions
so that everyone has a job.
Victor Hugo
between a government that does it wrong
and a people who consent to it,
there is an embarrassing complicity.
Arturo and Lía.
A nation is in danger when its President
speaks every day
and believes he is the most important person in his country.
Paulo Coelo.
When a says he will end poverty,
refers to yours.
Avoid Perón.
The people do not need their government
complains and blames his predecessor.
He was chosen to improve the situation,
to provide solutions.
To complain,
the people are already there.
George burner show
politicians and diapers must be changed
frequently,
both for the same reason.
John f.
Kennedy.
Ignorance of a voter in a democracy
endangers the safety of all.
And finally,
Mahatma Gandhi.
If there is an idiot in power
is because those who chose him are well represented.
This 2 024 votes free and well-informed